bonsoir à toutes et à tous bienvenue sur
mait bonsoir bonsoir le public bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous chers amis
bienvenue dans cette émission on va
parler de politique bienvenue si vous
nous regardez sur twitch bonsoir le chat
vous êtes avec nous bonsoir bonjour si
vous nous regardez sur Youtube bonjour
bonsoir si vous nous écoutez en podcast
très content de vous retrouver dans
l'émission backseat
et cette semaine comme chaque semaine on
prévoit d'avoir sur le plateau des
invités de très grande qualité des
créate et des créatrices de contenu sur
Internet qui viennent nous parler d'une
cause qui leur tient à cœur et ce soir
j'ai l'immense plaisir d'accueillir sur
ce plateau Lena de la chaîne scarabet
bonjour et Valentine de la chaîne
science de comptoir et on a un petit
jingle et on a pas de petit jingle ça va
arriver merci d'être avec nous si tu
veux le jingle ah vas-y faisle
jingle c'est incroyable incroyable non
non je me suis trompé excusez-moi la
régie il y a pas de jingle c'était pas
dans mon doc j'ai fait n'importe quoi
euh voilà voilà merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes toutes les deux donc vidéastes
sur Youtube vous êtes des créatrices de
contenu et vous êtes un petit peu
spécialisé dans les question de science
si on peut dire toi Valentine tu es
spécialisé dans des sujets très variés
donc en fait tuas pas de spécialité
particulière c'est je suis en train de
me rendre compte de l'absurdité de ma
phrase spécialiste en tout tu fais du
dans tu dans le léchage de cailloux par
exemple on en parlera on y reviendra
ouais ouais ouais ouais tu parles aussi
du pillage des océans tu parles
d'astrologie aussi tu as fait des vidéos
absolument passionnantes merci être avec
nous et toi Lena tu es un peu plus enfin
tu es autodidacte mais to bah toi tu es
plus spécialisé oui c'est ça tu parles
d'insectes c'est ça moi je fais de
l'entomologie donc c'est vraiment
l'étude des insectes redit le mot
barbare entomologie c'est l'entomologie
l'étude des insectes c'est ça et ben je
me coucherai encore moins con euh ok
trop bien et donc tu fais ta fa combien
de temps que toi tu l'as fait moi ça
fait depuis 2018 que je fais vraiment de
la vulgarisation j'ai commencé les
réseaux sociaux de manière vraiment plus
assidue il y a un an et demi à peu près
ok d'accord c'est ça était euh tu es
autodidacte parce que toi tu as une
formation dans le secteur de
l'audiovisuel si je dis pas de conneries
alors en fait je suis pas complètement
autodidacte je me suis formée dans
l'audiovisuel en pour commencer et après
en fait je me suis formée en entomologie
donc j'ai vraiment les deux formations
ça et que j'ai voulu fusionner parce que
c'était vraiment le partage avec le
public qui m'a intéressé le plus en fa
tu as bien raison toi Valentine toi tu
as une formation de géologie oui tu as
une formation de géologie tu as été
journaliste scientifique pour Sciences
et Avenir oui c'est ça à quel moment tu
as fait le Shift pour venir sur les
internets euh bah j'ai jamais vraiment
fait le shift j'ai fait les de en par en
fait et j'ai lancé ma chaîne pendant mon
Master en journalisme scientifique
d'accord et voilà et après mon contrat
pour Scien avenir je me suis dit allez
je me lance à temps plein j'ai envie
d'être
chôeuse let's go la YouTube
money donc ouais toi Lena tu le dis toi
tu parles d'entomologie culturelle aussi
tu avais décrit ça c'est quoi le
carctère culturel de l'entomologie du
coup en fait l'entomologie culturelle
c'est ma spécialité c'est l'étude des
insectes à travers l'histoire et dans
les différentes cultures c'est hyper
passionnant non mais c'est trop bien
parce qu'en fait du coup on est entouré
d'insectes tout le temps sur quasiment
tous les continents on va trouver des
insectes et et du coup en fait c'est
l'étude de cette place que va prendre
l'insecte dans la vie humaine et surtout
à travers les différentes cultures parce
que la mante religieuse elle est mal vue
dans un pays et dans un autre c'est elle
qui a créé la terre quoi donc il y a il
y a vraiment un énorme tremplin en il y
a des pays on parce que la MTE
religieuse j'ai l'impression que c'est
plutôt positif chez nous en en Europe
non euh oui alors en Europe c'est plutôt
positif en France on dit même qu'elle
guide les pèlerins parce que du coup il
y a cette manière de religion où on
normalement les les mains de la manth
pour trouver son chemin tandis qu'aux
États-Unis par exemple on dit qu'elle
crache dans l'œil des hommes pour les
rendre aveugles il y a un petit TW quand
même je savais pas du tout [__] c'est
hyper intéressant euh ok tu as fait des
docus aussi d'ailleurs c'est ça tu as
fait des docu tu fais pas que des vidéos
YouTube C tu as fait quoi comme docu
alors j'ai fait des docu sur le bombix
Mori c'est le verre à soi qui est une
qui qui c'est hyper passionnant il y a
plein de choses trop chouette avec cet
insecte parce que c'est devenu un animal
domestique à part entière c'est plus du
tout un animal qu'on peut trouver dans
dans le dans la vie sauvage et et il y a
un lien très particulier qui se crée
avec du coup ceux qui font de la
sériculture c'est le mot pour dire on
élève des vers à soi et et du coup sur
ça j'ai fait aussi les les insectes dans
la place dans l'art parce que pareil il
y a il y a une grosse symbolique autour
des insectes dans l'art et du coup à
travers certaines époques et du coup bah
voilà c'est et ben c'est trop bien on a
quelques extraits de ta chaîne qu'on va
regarder tout de suite on va regarder
les extraits et on continue à en parler
c'est l'occasion pour vous de découvrir
cette chaîne scarabette abonnez-vous on
regarde j'ai tourné une vidéo avec choco
si vous l'avez vu vous reconnaissez
sûrement petit pied et si vous êtes là
c'est peut-être parce que vous voulez en
adopter un ça c'est aubergine et ça
c'est courgette un joli début
deatatouille qui j'espère va me faire
beaucoup de petits bébés carottes
tomates et oignons tu te dis peut-être
que j'ai complètement perdu la boule
surtout si tu arrives par hasard et que
tu ne me connais pas mais non ce sont
bien mes animaux de compagnie bon allez
on revient à petit pied c'est un mil Pat
qui d'ailleurs n'a pas vraiment 1000
pattes mais plutôt environ maximum 750
et ce qui est rigolo avec eux c'est que
quand ils se sentent en danger hop ils
ont une technique de ouf ils se roulent
en boule la tête la première si tu aimes
les animaux stylés qui battent des
records du monde est-ce qu'il faut
prendre un iu oui madame voilà c'est la
chaîne scarabet que je vous invite à à
découvrir à vous abonner première
question comment vont petits pied
aubergine et courgette euh ils vont bien
aubergine à pondu euh et du coup non par
donc courgette àendue c'est la femelle
c'est aubergine le papa c'est aubergine
le papa malheureusement le papa n'est
plus parmi nous il s'est un peu trop
épuisé à force de reproduction mais bon
RIP courgette elle va très bien bon
pourquoi est-ce que tu penses que il
faut s'intéresser aux insectes les
insectes c'est vraiment la base de tout
en fait c'est la base de la vie c'est
eux à la base de la chaîne alimentaire
s'il y a pas d'insectes on aura pas à
manger on aura pas de pollinisation donc
c'est hyper important de base et ensuite
je trouve que c'est des animaux qui sont
sous côtés euh il y en a qui sont
incroyables avec des particularités
hyper étranges des des liens avec nous
qu'on soupçonne pas par exemple euh on
va parler des punaises de lit hein ça
existe depuis 4000 ans euh la la la
trace la plus ancienne qu'on a avec eux
c'est 4000 ans donc c'est énorme
Cléopâtre avait des punaises de lit mais
on se dit pas wou c'est ouf mon ancêtre
hyper lointain de l'Antiquité il avait
le même problème que moi ben si euh
pareil les moustiques aussi c'était un
problème et on lit par exemple chez les
grands philosophes antiques euh des
manières de combattre les moustiques et
notamment il faisait exprès de
construire les villes éloigné des des
des marécages enfin c'est des petits
trucs comme ça qu'on intéressant et
c'est pour ça que je trouve c'est des
animaux qui sont un peu sous côté en
plus il y en a ils sont vraiment très
beaux non mais c'est vraih le panda
c'est joli mais pardon maises courgettes
mais elle in elle incroyable courgette
elle incroyable courgette on t'aime non
mais carrément non non mais c'est c'est
c'est c'est hyper intéressant tu saurais
l'expliquer cette méfiance d'Ave des
insects évidemment il y a eu des des
message de dégoût dans le chat je attend
ce que je comprends tout à fait elle il
vient d'où ce dégoût cette les INSS les
petites pattes je sais pas on l' exploré
ça il y a plusieurs théories il y en a
une qui dit que on a une peur qui est
ancrée génétiquement alors tous les tous
les scientifiques ne sont pas d'accord
sur cette théorie mais en tout cas il y
a des études qui montrent que on aurait
des peurs en fait parce que du coup les
insectes posaient plus de problèmes
sanitaires
notamment qui vient de l'évolution c'est
ça que c'est ça et du coup on aurait
développé une espèce de peur ancrée
génétiquement après il y a l'autre qui
est la peur sociale qui est transmis de
génération en génération ou ça oui
celle-là elle est acceptée comme théorie
et et ensuite il y a tout un truc où ils
viennent nous déranger dans notre
confort parfois surtout les insectes t
les mouches les moustiques les cafars
les choses comme ça ils viennent nous
rappeler un peu à qu'on est des animaux
qu'on vit dans la nature et ça parfois
l'être humain moderne et occidental a du
mal àaccepter mais c'est une vision qui
est très occidentale encore une fois
dans certains pays on est beaucoup plus
à même de vivre avec ces insectes et on
les considère moins comme une nuisance
euh et et voilà en fait ça ça dépend
vraiment beaucoup de de là où on se
place dans le monde et toi du coup
Valentine tu as une chaîne je le disais
qui s'appelle science de comptoir là
aussi on a des extraits on vous les
balance tout de suite et on en parle ou
là là pou miner les océans pour sauver
la planète et se faire plein de brousouf
au passage compl ah non c'est pas ça
vous avez peut-être entendu parler du
depsy mining aujourd'hui les
scientifiques savent bien que non
planter des forêts n'est pas la solution
miracle pour lutter contre le changement
climatique c'est un des outil disponible
parmi un arsenal assez vaste
d'initiative de conservation de la
nature et en plus ça coûte vachement
cher pour un t de réussite pas joujour
quand je dis aux gens que j'ai fait des
études de géologie la première chose qui
me demande c'est qu'est-ce qui tourne
pas rond chez toi et la deuxième c'est
est-ce que les géologues lègent vraiment
des cailloux alors non seulement oui
pour la petite histoire on a même trouvé
de la monmorionite sur Mars donc si
jamais vous y allez vous pouvez très
bien lécher le sol et si ça reste collé
à votre langue et ben c'est que c'est de
la monomorionite ou alors c'est que vous
avez enlevé votre combinaison et du coup
votre tête a explosé elle est allée
rouler par terre elle est restée collé
au
sol du coup est-ce que tu lèches des
cailloux Valentine bien sûr mais
évidemment c pas plus tard qu'il y a une
semaine tu d'où tu viens toi du coup en
l'occurrence euh de quelle planète ou de
quelle
planè où est-ce que tu comment est-ce
que tu en es venu on en a parlé un petit
peu tout à l'heure tu viens du
journaliste tu as fait des études du
journaliste comment est-ce que tu en es
venu à t'intéresser aux enjeux
scientifiques tu as parlé même de
formation journalisme scientifique
toutit qu'est-ce qui t'a conduit vers
çait euh bah j'ai toujours beaucoup aimé
les sciences et un peu le côté
artistique de la chose et du coup je
cherch un un un métier qui soit à la à
la jointure des deux c'est pas le bon
terme mais on dira que voilà on on voilà
c'est mon côté
scientifique et et du coup c'est bien
parce que c'est bien la science c'est
une manière de devoir le monde mais
ouais non mais je suis bien d'accord
avec toi tu l'abordes avec humour la
science j'essaye est-ce que pour toi
c'est le truc le plus efficace est-ce
que ça a des
limites bah le plus efficace je sais pas
ça dépend du public ça dépend de ce
qu'on veut faire moi je suis clairement
dans la vibe divertissement et non pas
dans la vibe éducation enfin il a un peu
les deux mais ouais je sais pas juste
naturellement je suis du genre à faire
des blagues et à pas me prendre au séri
donc juste à coller bien quoi tu bosses
aussi pour haré avec un projet qui
s'appelle scope tout à fait tu nous en
parles un peu oui oui oui c'est un des
une émission qu'on fait en live sur
twitch sur le twitch d'art donc
.tv fr je sais plus brefpv ouais je
crois oui et et donc on fait des
émissions thématiques sur les sciences
et il y en a une qui arrive très bientôt
la semaine prochaine le 13 sur un sujet
que je ne vous dévoilerai pas les jeux
vidéo merci Valentine B écoute on a hâte
de la regarder il y a quelqu'un quiand
dans le chat comment s'appelle sa chaîne
sa chaîne s'appelle science de comptoir
euh n'hésitez surtout pas à aller à
aller aller la regarder Lena ta chaîne
s'appelle scarabet est-ce qu'on peut
parler 2 minutes parce qu'on est entre
nous de de ce phénomène de la vulga
scientifique sur Youtube c'est un truc
j'ai l'impression que c'est historique
sur Youtube j'ai des souvenirs de de de
les premières vague de vulgarisateurs
scientifiques qui ont porté la
plateforme avec eux il y avait l'humour
et ça on s'en souvient les Squeezie les
Cypriens et cetera mais très rapidement
il y a eu not Béné il y a eu y pensé il
y a eu science étonnante et puis enfin
il y a toute une là j'ai cité que des
mecs mais en fait il y a aussi plein de
plein de
Nan comment ça se fait que ça marche
aussi bien comment ça se fait que on
regarde jusqu'à 2h du matin des vidéos
sur des sujets qu'on savait même pas que
ça existait 2 heur avant bah parce qu'on
a envie de de s'instruire je sais pas
ouis c'est cool c'est oui non vas-y
excuse toi vas-y mon mon j'ai
l'impression aussi qu'on a grandi avec
ces pas sorciers qu'on a quand même été
vite mis dans des programmes enfin làà
je parle de ma génération on s pas
sorcier ça commence à vieillir mais mais
on a vachement eu quand même ce truc de
quand on est enfant d'essayer
d'apprendre en s'amusant et je pense que
ça répondait peut-être à cette demande
d'avoir un truc un peu plus adulte mais
sur Youtube je sais pas on a grandi
là-dedans et en plus pardon je vas-y
vas-y vas-y je suis
horrible en plus on n pas l'équivalent à
la télé enfin en tout cas il y a
vraiment une case vacante à la télé sur
la science même s'il y a des tentatives
à droite à gauche et du coup YouTube
était là pour répondre à cette demande
il y a quelqu'un dans le chat qui dit
est-ce que c'est pas un peu en train de
crever la vulga sur Youtube moi j'ai pas
du tout l'impression enfin pardon mais
j'ai l'impression que ça revi mais j'ai
même l'impression que ça marche du feu
de dieu enfin alors que ça revient
peut-être oui d'ailleurs peut-être qu'il
y a eu un ventre mou moment j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a eu un ventre mou
et que d'un coup là ça commence à
revenir l'engouement en tout cas pour
les chaînes les chaînes éducation les
chaînes é ouais c'est les chaîne vulga
aussi dans ce côté juste simplement
découverte enfin tu vois tu le carton
par exemple de villebrequin il réussisse
à intéresser à la bagnole des gens comme
moi bah CIT une forme de vulgar c'est
rend pas si je je dis ça ils nous ont
toujours pas expliqué ce que c'était que
le le différ mais mais mais non non je
je non je sais pas oui oui il y a quand
même un peu de vulgarisation il y a un
peu d'explication et non j'ai vraiment
pas l'impression non je sais pas dans le
chat vous me dites hein twitch monte pas
mal en vulgarisation scientifique ah
ouais non je sais pas il y a de la
vulgar scientifique sur Youtube j'en pas
tu connais scope oui mainant dis non
mais oui oui
avec scope et avec d'autres programmes
sur twitch peut-être mais d'autres je
sais en même temps si je dis ça non mais
c'est pas vrai parce qu'en fait il y a
les artisans qui nous montrent leur
artisanat les boulangers les lutiers
même il il y a tout un collectif qui
s'est monté sur twitch qui s'appelle po
science avec ple de voilà tout ce qu'on
prend et compagnie il y a non il y a du
mond il y a le knes oui le knes
effectivement qui qui qui font plein de
trucs aussi quand il y a des lancements
de d'Arian et cetera tu as raison
maintenant tu le dis Micot qui fait de
la vulga de fait non non complètement
j'ai c'est juste que j'y pensais pas
mais en fait il y en a plein puis a moi
je fais des vulgarisations sur la
science politique mais oui de faites oui
oui Non Non mais ouais carrément de
faites je je lu dis aussi qu'il y a un
petit truc où on est vite tapé
par l'humour ou par la le la
vulgarisation et la manière de de de
parler de certaines sciences et tout par
par des par des petites phrase qui fait
lécher les cailloux par exemple
clairement moi je je pense pas forcément
à regarder des vidéos sur la géologie
mais quelqu'un qui lèche les cailloux
oui il y a un truc je sais pas ça
m'attire et et je vais aller voir et du
coup j'ai l'impression de me faire
happer pareil vibrequin pour les
voitures personnellement je m'intéresse
pas trop aux voitures mais je regarde
les vidéos de villebrequin il y a le
designer automobile aussi qui fait des
super vidéos sur les les voitures et sur
les designs des voitures et moi j'en ai
rien à faire mais je trouve ça super
intéressant comme toi et c'est ce que
j'ai toujours aimé dans la vulga sur
Youtube c'est qu' c'est qu'ils arrivent
à me fasciner à me captiver sur des
enfin vous arrivez vous aussi toutes les
deux à me captiver sur des sujets encore
une fois 5 minutes avant je savais même
pas que le sujet existait quoi et et et
du coup c'est ça qui est cool mais ça
montre ouais effectivement quelque chose
sur la curiosité je sais pas il y a une
forme de de de mon côté je politise tout
mais euh ça dit peut-être quelque chose
de la volonté de de de d'avoir des yeux
ouvert sur le monde de comprendre
comment il fonctionne de s'intéresser de
s'interroger je sais pas cette idée que
les internautes sont des espèces de
moutons qui e que leur nombril et leurs
pieds et tout bah la preuve en fait on
passe tellement d'heur à regarder des
trucs sur des sujets qu'on connaît pas
je sais pas on tombe dans des rabbit
hall pendant des heures et bon on avait
le cliché avant je trouve du geek qui
joue au jeux vidéos dans sa chambre
alors qu'en fait on se rend alors que
ben non c'est des gens qui sont hyper au
contraire du coup internet donne accès à
plein de cultures différentes et qui du
coup on peut connaître pourquoi est-ce
qu'on lèche des caillou et le design des
voitures il y a PF qui dit dans le chat
sur le système éducatif ouais mais alors
là attention faut pas opposer les deux
enfin je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
mais la vulgare le vulgarisateur n'est
pas le concurrent du prof c'est pas du
tout le même job absolument pas c'est un
une aide à la limite mais non on
remplace pas les profs ne serait-ce que
parce que notre public est content de
venir nous
voir bonne rentrée scolaire les
profs j'embrasse ma cousine qui est
prof non en plus il y en a plein il y en
a plein qui sont profs et qui font de la
vulga aussi donc non non non c'est
support différent c'est c'est un contenu
différent c'estit chose et puis ouis et
puis nous on pas le temps de creuser
aussi on va pas donner un cours de
biologie pure parce que on n pas le
temps dans une vidéo de 10 minutes ça
remplace pas un cours de 50 minutes sur
sur les insectes et leur comportement ou
leur biologie c'est imp possible quoi
mais c'est c'est même d'un certain point
de vue notre rôle à nous les
vulgarisateurs c'est de générer la
curiosité chez les gens qui regardent
pour que le lendemain en cours il lève
la main il pose une question au prof
parce que parce que je sais pas parce
qu'on aura éveillé sa curiosité un truc
comme ça ça m déjà arrivéc des profs
témoignent en disant [__] j'ai un
lycéen il est venu me voir il m'a parlé
du fait majoritaire et du 493 je savais
pas quoi lui répondre apparemment il a
vu une de tes vidéos je suis largué et
cetera et c'était super sympa de la part
du prof de me dire [__] tu as réussi à
l'intéresser sur un truc de barge et
mais donc tant mieux en fait c'est bon
courage les profs en vrai gros big up à
vous en plus vous en prenez plein la
gueule c'est vraiment pas facile mais
euh mais voilà en plus dans le chat là
vous êtes tous depuis tout à l'heure à
vous partager des des des chaînes de
vulgarisation qui existent sur twitch ou
sur Youtube et c'est aussi ce qui est
cool dans la vulga j'ai l'impression
d'avoir plus de facilité à dire à mes
potes oh j'ai découvert la chaîne tu
connais la nouvelle mais j'ai plus
souvent l'habitude de faire ça sur de la
vulgar que sur d'autres trucs sur
l'humour ou sur des centres d'intérêts
de geek que je peux avoir par ailleurs
donc euh donc ouais non c'est cool h
est-ce que vous pensez que l'avenir de
la vulgarisation est sur Youtube est-ce
que vous pensez que les vieux médias
sont morts comment vous voyez ça euh les
vieux médias je saurais pas dire mais je
pense que l'avenir est pas que sur
youtube il est un peu partout là il y a
il y a un peu une explosion des contenus
éducatifs aussi sur TikTok sur Instagram
enfin les formats cours je trouve qu'il
y a énormément de choses à faire
là-dedans mais encore une fois c'est
vraiment juste pour allumer une
étincelle quoi on est pas là pour
expliquer des trucs en 2 3 minutes on
peut on peut rien dire quoi juste on
balance une anecdote ou deux et puis
voilà mais je pense qu'il y a plein de
trucs à faire sur plein de médias
différents ouais ouais non mais
carrément je suis d'accord avec toi
c'est quoi vous les meilleurs retours
que vous avez eu parce que moi j'ai
raconté ce retour là comme une anecdote
mais c'est quoi les trucs qui vous ont
le plus marqué de retour de votre public
moi je crois c'est les messages privés
qui me disent ah avant j'écrasé les
insectes parce que j'aimais pas ça et
maintenant je les prends en photo et je
les
envoie compte quoi il y a des gens qui
ont adopté des insectes après avoir vu
tes vidéos oh c'est trop bien plein
plein si je reçois tous les jours des
messages de gens qui me disent ah j'ai
envie d'adopter des phasmes comment je
fais ah j'ai envie d'adopter des
papillons comment je fais enfin plein de
trucs comme ça et du coup ça c'est cool
c'est trop cool et toi alors les miens
veulent adopter du gnice et c'est plus
facile d'entretien c'est quoi le gnice
pour ceux qu'on pas la r euh c'est un
type de roche voilà pas très intéressant
vous pouvez la lécher voilà on peut la
lécher l'uranium essayer d'éviter mais
le GL vous pouvez y aller non mais oui
effectivement le le truc de base c'est
de dire je m'intéresse pas du tout au
caillou mais je regarde ta chaîne ça
c'est génial parce que du coup il y a il
y a des gens qui apprennent des trucs et
tout enfin ça me fascine des fois je
reçois pas mal de photos de gens qui me
disent ça c'est quoi comme
caillou j'aime bien mais mettez vos
mettez une échelle sur la photo sinon
c'est diffic difficile oui s'il vous
plaît faitesle enfin je dis ça c'est pas
pour moi c'est pour Valentine m'envoyz
pas de photos de caillou j'aurais pas
quoi vous dire il est droite ou il est
gauche ce caillou c'est
rien vraiment bon eu scarabet et science
de comptoir on vous a invité toutes les
deux pour parler d'un sujet qui aussi un
petit peu dans l'actu ce sont les
punaises de lit et on va en parler mais
avant ça ça va être introduit par une
super séquence c'est parti pour le
powerp de
[Applaudissements]
Vincent V faut que je m'installe
attendez après je mais j'ai un câble à
brancher enfin c'est le powerpo
installe-toi oui alors ça c'est grand
changement de la saison 3 ce n'est plus
la régie qui passe les slides c'est
Vincent directement sur son ordi euh
nous sommes des professionnels j'adore
le en fait la rythmique tout ça j'ai ma
tablette pour mon texte vraiment j'ai
l'impression d'être Hugo de la crypte en
c'est j'adore aujourd'hui dans
l'actualité
bref salut c'est Hugo vous allez bien ça
va et toi Vincent ça fait plaisir de te
voir bah ouais mais en plus moi la
semaine dernière je suis désolé j'étais
pas là eu j'avais j'avais le covid c'est
la et j'ai fait une décision qui a pu
qui a peut-être un peu choqué dans je
sais pas les gens mais j'ai décidé de
m'isoler euh pour pas contaminer voilà
ça se fait encore certains essayent
voilà donc hésitez pas hésitez pas euh
mais rassurez-vous he aujourd'hui je
reviens avec un un gros gros sujet je
vais parler d'un ce parasite qui nous
agace tous
alors alors il y a lui aussi mais c'est
c'est je parlais d'un autre parasite
effectivement cette semaine on m'a
proposé de parler des des punaises de
lit parce que c'est vrai que c'est le
sujet médiatique du du moment et et
c'est parti un peu dans dans tous les
sens on va pararler après mais j'ai vu
que Bernard Verbert était devenu expert
en sexualité DEP punaise deolis sur BFM
TV je vous ai mis un cour extrême j'en
pouvais plus je crois qu'on a la la
vidéo la punaise d' a une sexualité
torde parce que ils ont plus de 200
rapports sexuels par jour par jour alors
qu'il y a peu d'humains qui arrivent à
cette performance et
deuxièmement la quantité de sperme lâché
est gigantesque ça correspondra à
plusieurs litres par rapport à notre
taille humaine voilà donc merci Bernard
merci
BFM VO onarler tout mais en fait ça me
ça me tu parce qu'il était très content
de faire ces petites blagues les humains
voilà bref c'était c'était drôle et par
contre pas de King Shiming sur la
sexualité des punaise de lit on n'est
pas là on n'est pas là pour ça mais moi
quand j'ai vu ce sujet monter ces
dernières semaines j'ai pas été surpris
en fait parce que sans vouloir faire le
hipster moi ça fait des années que les
punaises de lit me font peurin je dis je
dis ça mais j'avais peur des punaises de
lit avant que ça soit cool d'avoir peur
des punesses de lit j'essaie pas de me
placer a-dessus de la mêlée mais voilà
factuellement j'avais j'avais cette peur
là de depuis longtemps et et puis voilà
moi c'est vrai que je je suis terrifié à
l'idée de d'ouvrir mon lit et de trouver
des des punaises de lit ou ou Pascal pro
he
mais mais ce que je veux dire en fait
c'est c'est ça ça m'a quand même
questionné ce que je me suis dit mais
pourquoi pourquoi on en parle maintenant
en fait pourquoi donc c'est la question
que je vais vous poser ce soir là
j'adore par que je peux faire les
animations ça prend grave du temps
j'adore attendez voilà hop
là applaudissement pour Vincent elle est
vachement bien
FA
euh trop mignonne la punaise je trouve
euh c'est c'est fait avec M de journée
voilà
euh je pose la question parce qu'en soi
c'est vrai qu'il y a il y a rien de il y
a rien de de nouveau en 2022 donc le
syndicat des industries de
désinsectisation a totalisé plus d'un
million d'interventions professionnelles
contre 200000 en 2017 donc c'est c'est
une hausse à peu près de 15 à 20 % en en
5 ans donc ça fait des années que c'est
un problème et j'irai même plus loin en
rappelant que les punaises de lit éent
là avant nous sur terre en 2019 il y
avait une étude de curent biology qui
disait que les punaises de lis sont sur
terre depuis 115 millions d'années euh
et qu' donc elles ont survécu à
l'extinction des des dinosures donc les
les punaises sont costaudes elles vont
elles vont à la salle quoi elles
prennent de la prot elles prennent de la
way elles suivent les tutos de de thbao
inshape et en fait depuis bah l'humanité
n'a cessé de les côtoyer parfois sans le
savoir et dans la culture historique et
populaire on retrouve toujours ce petit
ce petit nuisible dans les peintures
rupestres à la Renaissance ou même au
cinéma ça a été vraiment un sujet
récurrent moi non j'arrête là encore
c'était mi-journée voilà j'ai j'ai fait
grâce à un copain qui s'appelle Valentin
que j'embrasse j'ai fait des petits
promptes comme ça mais je trouve que les
résultats sont quand même assez
impressionnants faut le dire et mais en
fait cette petite tentative de blague
visuelle me permet de d'arriver au cœur
du du sujet et de l'une des explications
sur pourquoi selon moi ça Pope
maintenant c'est qu'en fait les punaes
de lit avant de devenir des des
personnages médiatiques en fait je
trouve que c'est un personnage qui était
fait et qui est né pour les réseaux
sociaux en fait je m'explique il y a
d'abord la bah la la la figure de la
punaise que donc c'est on appelle ça
scientifiquement c'est la la simex
lectularius si je me trompe pas voilà
pour pour les pour les intimes donc
c'est un hisible c'est un un être qui
est pas très Jol j'ai remplacé les
visuels pour pas trigger de de gens dans
dans le public ou sur sur le chat mais
en gros euh voilà c'est un usible en
plus les conséquences sur la santé
mentale des personnes qui peuvent avoir
ça chez eux c'est assez c'est assez
catastrophique et euh donc je trouve
qu'en fait de base la punesse de lit on
a envie de s'en moquer euh parce que on
a envie de se défouler dessus et je
trouve qu'en plus ça c'est c'est une
bonne manière de d'ironiser sur les
pires aspects de la vie urbaine euh et
d'alimenter une forme bah un peu de de
tendance un peu un peu humoristique et
euh moi ça me rappelle ça me rappelle
pas mal euh euh à New York la la figure
en fait du euh du rat euh à New York en
fait c'est un vrai problème aussi euh
là-bas euh il y a un parallèle je trouve
qui est assez intéressant parce que que
en fait le Race c'est devenu un peu une
star des réseaux sociaux aussi il y a
même une sorte de tourisme il y a un
tiktokeur qui filme les rat et qui
invite les gens à faire un peu des
chasses au rat pour les filmer pour le
mettre sur les réseaux sociaux je pense
aussi au fameux pizza rat c'était un un
rat qui était devenu célèbre il y a
quelques années parce qu'il a été filmer
en train de de s'échapper avec une une
part de pizza dans la bouche on la remet
je pense vous la connaissez mais on on a
la vidéo juste
pour oh là là c'est un New York comm un
autre
quoi mais elle revient elle revient elle
revient B elle attend parce qu'elle a un
peu peur elle voit qu'elle est filmé
mais elle va revenir elle lâche pas
l'affaire et tout voilà donc en fait il
y a il y a des pizzarat c'est devenu un
peu un emblème aussi de la ville et
cetera
et il y a il y a même j'ai vu il y a il
y a quelques semaines à peine il y a le
maire de New York qui a nommé une tsare
des rat Katheline coradi pour gérer le
problème c'est comme si dans quelques
mois il y a un peu de bruit je sais pas
si tout va bien c'est comme si dans
quelques mois il y avait un un préposé
au punais de lit qui était nommé par
annidalgo quoi et je trouve que ça assez
en fait les possibilités sont assez
folles et et en fait la punèe de lis
c'est un vrai problème de santé publique
ça et je trouve que ça pourrait voilà
devenir une figure un peu populaire dans
la ville qu'on pourrait classer bah
entre ratatouille et les légendes
urbaines du crocodile dans dans les
égouts et cetera je pense qu'il y a un
truc symbolique qui peut qui peut se
mettre en place et je trouve que aussi
un autre point intéressant c'est que la
punae de lit c'est un être vivant qui
par définition se propage elle se
multiplie elle se faufile elle peut
passer d'humain en humain et elle peut
bah se transformer muter et cetera
exactement comme les mêmes en fait sur
sur internet de base c'est fait pour
pour se répandre au début sur Twitter
c'était surtout une petite blague entre
parisiens sur certaines salles du MK2
dans le nord-est de Paris et puis bah
progressivement cet été un peu tout a
changé sur les réseaux parce que il y a
les les alertes qui se sont diversifié
en gros comme certains même les punaises
de lis se sont un peu décentralisés pour
ce qu'on la RF euh et on a vu donc en
août il y a eu d'abord un ou là attendez
je spoil Ohou là là en août il y a eu
d'abord un premier témoignageune
certaine Nawal qui qui témoignait sur le
UGC de Bercy Village puis ensuite la
punaise de lit voyage en en classe écho
mais elle voyage donc on la voit
soi-disant dans le TGV et cetera et tout
donc ça ça commence à ça commence à se à
se répondre il y a eu un lî Flandre euh
voilà la crainte commence à grandir
parce qu'en plus il y a des vidéos des
photos des gens qui critiquent qui qui
dit ah oui ça'en est sen est pas et
cetera donc ça crée aussi pas mal de
discussions et après bah c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment l'avalanche il y a un
conducteur de la ligne 8 qui a dit qu'il
en avait vu même si ça a été démenti il
y a eu des services d'urgence qui ont dû
un peu fermer euh des collèges des des
classes et cetera et peu importe en fait
s'il y a des démenti chaque signalement
et que chaque signalement n'est pas
forcément véridique et ben en fait c'est
un peu c'est un peu trop tard parce que
même si c'est difficile de mesurer
vraiment le l'ampleur l'ampleur du
phénomène bah pour les réseaux sociaux
ce genre de de propagation on va dire
bah c'est vraiment du pain béni et moi
ça m'a rappelé une histoire ça m'a
rappelé alors je sais pas si vous en
souvenez cé à l'été 2020 l'histoire des
chevaux mutilé il y avait eu beaucoup
beaucoup de fake news autour de cette
histoire là et il y avait notamment
quelques plaisantins qui avaient lancé
la rumeur que c'était Nagi le
présentateur Nagi qui était responsable
de la mutilation des des chevaux
évidemment c'était délirant et tout mais
c'est resté un des arcs narratifs du
Twitter français que je trouve le plus
marquant en tout cas facil ça été un
vrai phénomène mé et en fait je me dis
qu' il y a quelque chose d'un peu d'un
d'un peu similaire avec ça mais à la
différence et là encore c'est le dernier
point qui est très important c'est que
les punaises de lit ça touche à un sujet
sensible c'est les Jeux Olympiques qui
auront lieu en 2024 à Paris et donc le
voit avec la la couverture médiatique
mondiale oui évidemment j'ai fait une
petite une petite sélection de
différents médias italiens allemands
anglais et cetera il y a un enjeu
d'image il y a un enjeu politique
économique il y a un enjeu jeu sanitaire
évidemment qui joue qui se joue autour
de cette petite bestiole et donc parce
que les punaises de lit permettent euh
de créer des mêmes et des blague sur le
sujet très controversé des des Jeux
Olympiques et ben ça ça lui permet de
gagner encore plus de puissance je
trouve sur sur les réseaux ça en devient
même un outil de bataille politique hein
vous allez en parler mais on a vu voilà
mathil Panau qui brandit une une fiole
remple de punaise à l'Assemblée
nationale au même moment où LFI via
certaines enquêtes diffusé la télévision
subit un petit peu un un certain
contrecoup on a aussi vu beaucoup de
blagues sur annidalgo annidalgo qui est
souvent la cible de Vann sur les réseaux
sociaux bah il y a des blagues qui ont
été faites il y a des politiques qui ont
même dit voilà la ville la plus touchée
c'est Paris qui a la tête de Paris c'est
Madame hiidalgo voilà c'est vraiment ce
truc de voilà profitons-en et tout et et
donc en fait vous l'avez compris la
punaise de lit bah elle a vraiment en
plus d'envoahir nos appartements ça on
le sait pas vraiment c'est difficile
encore une fois à quantifier mais je
trouve qu'elle était vraiment vent fait
pour envahir les réseaux sociaux il y a
vraiment une contamination qui est assez
intéressante et moi je vais pour
conclure ça m'a fait penser à à quelque
chose qui m' arrivé il y a quelques
semaines je sortais d'un rendez-vous et
je traversais la scène et j'assiste à je
vois sur une espèce de pneumatique qui
éta en train de tourner des images pour
un film et j'ai appris par la suite que
le film en question et je vous jure
c'est pas desbar c'est un film Netflix
qui va parler de l'attaque de requin
pendant une épreuve de triathlon dans
pendant les les pendant les Jos enfin
peut-être pas forcément les Jos ça ser
peut-être pas brander comme ça mais
c'est une attaque de requin pendant une
épreuve de triathlon avec berenis beot
ENF j'ai hâte de voir ça et en fait là
je me suis dit donc je me suis dit mais
en fait je sais pas ce que c'est
toujours un peu en prod et cetera et
tout je me dis si les scénaristes de
Netflix ils sont malins et ben en fait
il remplace le requin par des punaises
de lit et ça serait beaucoup plus
réaliste et ça serait beaucoup plus
flippant et enfin voilà je sais pas
c'est juste une petite idée que je lise
comme ça avant de vous dire bonsoir et
de vous remercier de m'avoir écouté
voilà passer une bonne soirée merci
beaucoup vent pour ce powerp
exceptionnel merci beaucoup Vincent euh
pour ce powerp extrêmement intéressant
effectivement les punaises de lit ont t'
envahi nos nos réseaux sociaux mais
aussi nos appartements on va on va en
parler
euh Vincent l'a abordé rapidement dans
sa dans sa chronique il a parlé de la
sexualité des pununaes de lit Valentine
tu voulais nous en parler aussi oh oui
vas-y oh oui alors j'ai préparé une
petite chronique elle s'appelle 5
minutes pour faire ban ta chaîne on va
voir on va voir vas-y alors si ça vous
démange rien que de parler des punaises
de Ji parce que moi j'étais pas bien là
pendant tout la bref attendez d'entendre
sur la sexualité hein n déplaise à
Bernard verber je sais pas pourquoi je
parle comme ça pour donner le temps
quand vous tapez reproduction des
punesses de lit dans Google enfin dans
votre moteur de recherche préféré tant
que c'est pas celui qui plante des
arbres là vous tombez sur la page
insémination traumatique voilà ça donne
le
ton d'ailleurs toute ressemblance avec
le comportement de certains youtubeur
serait purement fortite donc parlons des
punaises et de leur édéage alors c'est
pas un euphémisme et tu regrettes déjà
ou là non non non jusque là je suis ça
roule donc edage c'est le nom du petit
robinet d'amour des insectes et
d'ailleurs sachez que chaque espèce a un
edage bien particulier un petit robinet
bien particulier on peut s'en servir
pour identifier les espèces tu me dis si
si je me trompe hein c'est tout bon ok
voilà chacun son truc perso si je me
présente à la Douine je préfère juste
montrer mon passeport mais chacun son
truc après pas de King shaming donc les
DH de la punase de lit revenons-en au
microscope c'est un genre de seringue ou
de poignard c'est vous qui voyez hein
c'est pas un comme l'é taches de rorchat
vous y voyez ce que vous voulez quand il
est temps donc pour le malâ de
disséminer ses gênnes il chope la
femelle et il l'empale avec son dart
d'amour voilà il l'empale pour de vrai
gen vraiment c'est ouais il l'empale gen
voilà sans les bruitages voilà je sais
pas comment on demande son consentement
à une punaise mais je crois pas que ce
soit comme ça en tout cas mais là où
c'est encore mieux enfin non pas pas le
bon choix de mot c'est qu'en fait les
insectes ont pas dauquelettes comme nous
vous savez c'est mou c'est mou et au
bout d'un moment c'est dur chez les gens
normaux moi c'est surtout beaucoup mou
en fait chez les insectes c'est un
exosquelette donc en fait il y a une
espèce
d'armureintérieur et c'est moi
l'intérieur voilà quand vous écrasez un
insecte ça fait alors que si vous
écrasez un humain ça
fait moyen némotechnique
dans je l'ai c'est pas de moi c'est pas
de moi donc je sais même plus où j'en
éta ave cette voilà donc le mâle doit
insérer son glève dans le corps de la
femelle en transperçant son squelette
imaginez la violence du truc ouais
ensuite il va lui injecter le principe
actif directement dans le corps avec sa
seringue et lui délivre le passe
sanitaire en passant euh oui donc il
s'en fout en fait de repérer les voies
génitales de la femelle juste il lui
transpce le bide et elle se démerde donc
voilà c'est c'est une autre façon de
faire après ça les petits soldats du
mâle vont voyager dans le sang de la
femelle on dit pas sang en vrai on dit
hmolymphe je me permets de voilà parce
qu'on sait jamais euh là ils vont faire
un petit tour gratuit duunomè donc sur
votre gauche voici l'œil sur votre
droite c'est le pro thorax devant vous
les terminus tout le monde descend et à
ce moment-là le sperme va descendre et
il va féconder l'ovule ou alors il va
être mis de côté côté par la femelle
dans une poche spéciale qu'on appelle la
spermatque et la femelle va pouvoir s'en
servir à loisir après si on en a besoin
un peu comme la fameuse bouteille voilà
un peu comme la fameuse bouteille de
ketchup qu'on garde au fond du frigo et
là là vous vous dites le calvaire est
fini et bien non pas du tout parce que N
dé plaise à Christine Boutin les
insectes c'est plutôt 400 papas une
maman non voilà et bon en l'occurrence
pour les punaises tu regrettes
maintenant ise c'est plutôt 5 papa une
maman mais je suis un peu marseillaise
d'adoption donc faut pas me croire quand
je dis des chiffres voilà donc non
seulement le vaccin lui-même est un peu
traumatique mais en plus vous payez 400
millions de rappels directement après
Macron
destitution voilà après tous les
accouplements qu'elle subissent du coup
les femelles elles sont un peu mal en
point voilà elles peuvent perdre du sang
les PL peuvent s'infecter parfois parce
qu'il y a plein de bactéries un peu sur
tout tout toutes ces choses d'amour
elles peuvent même en mourir donc en
gros leur leur espérance de vie diminue
drastiquement et pour limiter la C elles
ont développé quand même la joie de la
coévolution c'est qu'elles ont développé
un genre de cible molle sur l'abdomen
qu'on appelle un spermaledge en anglais
je sais pas comment on dit en français
un organe pour dire au mal visez là là
plutôt là là c'est ça fera moins mal là
voilà avec plus ou moins de de succès
évidemment parce que les
hommes la question pour finir c'est
pourquoi pourquoi l'évolution pourquoi
il y a plusieurs hypothèse l'une d'entre
elles c'est que pas le temps en fait on
a pas le time on veut gagner le temps
donc on économise bonjour comment tu
t'appelles on économise un resto ça
laisse plus de temps pour pouvoir créer
de la valeur comme ça pour miner du
Bitcoin je sais pas ce que vous voulez
avec votre temps on a commencé du coup
en parlant d'dâ alors j'aimerais finir
de la même manière pas comme les
femelles punais juste la la chronique de
la même manière il y a même des
récepteurs figurez-vous des
chimiécepteurs sur le pénis de la punae
de lit qui lui permettent de goûter la
femelle donc quand il est en en place il
peut savoir si quelqu'un est déjà passé
avant ou pas en fait voilà comme ça il
sait s'il est plutôt première nation ou
alors juste Christophe Colomb quoi et et
comme ça il va adapter la quantité de
poussière d'étoile qui va injecter à la
femelle derrière et c'est beau en tout
cas si vous étiez dégoûté jusqu'à
maintenant d'avoir des punaises de lit
chez vous dites-vous que maintenant vous
savez ce qu'elles font sous vous et
peut-être même dans vos interstices
pendant que vous dormez merci merci
[Applaudissements]
Valentine merci beaucoup Valentine
c'était on a appris beaucoup de choses
plus que ce qu'on aurait probablement
voulu savoir mais c'est ça qui est beau
avec la connaissance finalement il y en
a jamais assez merci beaucoup Lena toi
tu as fait plusieurs vidéos sur ta
chaîne pour parler avec ton public de ce
sujet le sujet des punaes de lit on
regarde une vidéo on en parle tout de
suite Bradley Cooper a déjà eu des
punaises de lit mais plus étonnant
cléopâre aussi et oui elles existent
depuis très longtemps ces petites bêtes
en fait à la base on pense que c'était
des parasites des chauv-souris qui
vivaientent dans des grottes et qu'elles
ont petit à petit évolué jusqu'à devenir
des parasites des humains oui ça me
gratte et d'ailleurs les premières
traces écrites qu'on a depunaise de lit
date de 4000 ans quand même donc ça
commence à faire un bail oh et
d'ailleurs on peut lire des petites
pépites quand on regarde les traitements
antiunais de l'époque moi Démocrite je
préconise de mettre des pieds de lapin
au pied du lit oui pour le coup ça
n'aura aucune conséquence sauf pour les
petits lapins sinon on propose de
pulvériser du cianure dans la pièce ah
bah ça pour le coup ça devrait marcher
sur les punaises de lit mais aussi sur
les humains bon les plus aisés ils
avaient vite compris la combine ont
jartait tout de la pièce et ont
rachetait le maximum mais ça t ch tout
ça voilà c'est un extrait d'une vidéo
que vous pouvez retrouver sur la chaîne
scarabette que je vous invite à à
découvrir si c'est pas encore fait Lena
est-ce que la punae de lis c'est un
insecte comme les autres alors euh comme
les autres il ressemble à beaucoup
d'autres insectes mais il est assez
particulier parce que c'est un insecte
parasite c'est-à-dire que il va vivre au
dépend d'un autre et là l'autre en
l'occurrence c'est nous leab des
punaises de lit nous donc il aime
vraiment particulièrement notre sang
c'est vraiment nous qui vaenir parasiter
et du coup c'est ce qui on fait quand
même un insecte assez spécial en en
voilà on on précise qu'il y a eu 1
million d'interventions contre les
punaises de lit en 2022 c'est une
augmentation de 200000 en un an donc on
est alors je sais pas si on est face à
un phénomène en nombre de punaises de
lit est-ce que il y a véritablement une
explosion ou est-ce que c'est que les
gens sont plus alerte c'est que parce
qu'on en parle bah les gens il ils
regardent sousfin ils en trouvent et que
du coup ils appellent à faire des
interventions je saurais pas dire mais
est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que est-ce
que est-ce qu'il y a un caractère
phénoménal parce que dans ta vidéo tu
dis que ça fait 4000 ans que ça existe
ça devrait pas être un un sujet
particulièrement nouveau alors en fait
faut savoir que les les punaises de lit
ça fait 2000 depuis 2017 qu'on a
vraiment une augmentation chaque année
qui est un peu significative il y avait
déjà eu en 2021 pas mal de d'articles
sur les punaises de li notamment au cru
avec les les étudiants qui se
retrouvaient avec des des des chambres
infestées de punaise de lit et certains
cru qui ne voulaient rien faire pour
inter enfin
pour arrêter les invasions donc il faut
savoir effectivement qu'il y a une
petite augmentation enfin une petite une
augmentation chaque année depuis 2017
qui qui fait l'objet de plusieurs
alertes de la part de divers organismes
en revanche en 2023 il y a pas d'un coup
un énorme boom de punaise de lit si vous
aviez pas peur il y a 1 an vous avez à
peine plus vous ariez de raison d'avoir
à peine plus de peur là cette année d'c
il y en a qui lent ça au réchauffement
climatique en disant que les insectes en
gros elle a moins de prédateur qu'avant
parce que parce qu'on sait que la
biodiversité est touchée très
directement par les changements
climatiques est-ce que c'est vrai est-ce
que tu as une info là-dessus ou pas
ouais alors la punesse de lit elle a pas
vraiment de prédateur principal à part
nous parce que le le truc c'est que elle
elle est du coup elle a évolué pour nous
parasiter nous humains et elle est très
peu intéressée par tout ce qui est
autres animaux alors elle peut de temps
en temps aller paralyser les animaux
domestiques parce que du coup ils sont
dans la pièce et du coup ça va être
aussi des des cibles qui vont pouvoir
cibler quand par exemple ils n'ont pas
d'autres humains apportter par contre
c'est très rare et euh c'est devenu des
insectes qui vont aller dans des
chambres et nous on ne laisse plus les
animaux aller dans nos maisons donc on a
plus de petits rongeurs qui pourrai
éventuellement s'en nourrir on a plus de
d'araignée qui pourrai venir combattre
les les punaise de lit euh ouis on fait
la chasse aux toiles d'Ar on fait la
chasse aux moustiqu on fait la chasse
aux souris au rats et exactement c'est
plutôt un insecte qui est assez
euh particulier dans ce domaine là c'est
qu'il n'a pas forcément vraiment de
prédateurs qui vont pouvoir venir avoir
un un impact sur les punaises de lit euh
tu disais tout à l'heure que la plupart
des insectes il sont à la base de la
chaîne alimentaire la punase de lit elle
a elle sert à quoi c'est compliqué c'est
une question qui est compliquée c'est un
insecte parasite souvent les parasites
ils sont là du coup pour réguler les
populations euh pour le coup on n pas de
il y a aucune preuve qui dit que les
punaises de lit sont porteurs de maladie
donc ils sont là pour se nourrir ils ont
une place dans l'écosystème parce qu'ils
ont réussi à avoir cette petite place là
ils ont réussi à avoir cette petite
niche après après tout animal qui
disparaît se fait remplacer dans la
biodiversité mais là bon on va pas dire
que il va y avoir un énorme trou si la
punaises de lit disparaît en revanche il
faut s'enlever de la tête qu'on peut
éradiquer les punaises de lit maintenant
c'est même plus imaginable d'accord euh
est-ce que l'on sait ce qui explique
cette augmentation j'ai vu la question
posée dans le chat depuis 2017 est-ce
qu'on connaît les facteurs qui
permettent d'expliquer ce ce retour des
punaises de lit est-ce que c'est que en
France est-ce que c'est en Europe est-ce
que c'est dans tous les pays développés
enfin tu vois je sais pas alors c'est
partout dans le monde les réchauffement
clim effectivement c'est une raison
qu'on voit beaucoup amener sur le débat
public mais en fait c'est plus plus
généralement la chaleur qui fait que le
cycle de la vie de la punaise de lit est
réduite donc plus il fait chaud plus les
œufs vont éclore vite plus les adultes
vont muer rapidement et du coup vont
pouvoir se reproduire rapidement
d'accord donc c'est pour ça que on dit
que le réchauffement climatique a un
impact et effectivement quand il fait
chaud là on a un mois d'octobre qui est
particulièrement clément on va voir que
la reproduction et les interventions
pour agir sur sur les punaises de lit
vont encore continuer pendant je pense
jusqu'à novembre voire même si on
continue comme ça peut-être début
décembre et et ça c'est c'est
problématique parce que il y a plus de
place à avoir une grosse invasion de
punaise de lit en fait d'accord ok
est-ce que l'hiver sera bénéfique la
question est posée dans le chat alors
l'hiver dans nos contrées fait que la
punaise se met en dormance et donc
arrête de venir se nourrir et arrête du
coup de se reproduire et du coup
l'invasion va se réduire
par contre elle se met en dormance et
dès qu'il va refaire beau elle va
recommencer donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut traiter très rapidement quand on a
des punaises de lit même quand on
chauffe chez nous euh bah du coup ça va
dépendre de comment est-ce qu'on chauffe
par exemple moi je suis sous l'étoit je
descends rarement en dessous de 18°gr
c'est largement suffisant pour que les
punèes de lit elles continuent il y a
des logements où on chauffe plus ou
moins et du coup bah là si vous chffez
avant chez vous effectivement elles vont
pas se mettre en dormance il y a
quelqu'un qui demande comment est-ce
qu'on sait qu'on a des punaises de lit
chez nous est-ce queil y a que les les
piqures les des mangeaisons qui nous
permet d'identifier le fait qu'on a un
problème ou est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut
simplement les chercher oui bah alors il
y a plusieurs signes la première c'est
les piqûes euh sachant que c'est assez
difficile quand même de différencier les
piqûes de punaise de lit de piqûes par
exemple de moustique c'est un peu
compliqué on peut avoir des des petits
signes les dermatologues souvent
réussissent à un peu plus essayer
d'épingler si telle ou telle piqû euh
donc on a les piicure elle gratte très
fort généralement sachant que chacun a
des sensibilités particulières mais
ensuite euh la deuxième chose à vérifier
c'est son matelas et notamment son drap
si on voit des petites traces de sang
c'est assez spécifique des punaises de
lit parce que du coup le moustique ne va
pas laisser une trace de sang quand
typique tandis que la punaise de lit oui
en général va laisser une trace ensuite
c'est de soulever le drap de changer les
draps complètement et on va essayer de
trouver des œufs on va essayer de
trouver des excréments les excréments
c'est tout noir et ça ressemble un petit
peu à de la moisissû c'est assez assez
spécifique et et voilà ça c'est les
principaux euh
signe à regarder pour vérifier si on a
des punaises de lit chez soi est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on fait si on apprend si on
découvre voilà qu'on a des punais de lit
est-ce qu'il y a des numéros de
téléphone est-ce qu'il y a des des
actions spécifiques qu'on doit faire
mettre en place alors on panique pas
déjà vraiment faut enlever la il faut en
arrivant en comprenant comment
fonctionne la punaise de lit et surtout
comment ça fonctionne une invasion de
punaise de lit il faut qu'on arrive à
calmer déjà parce que le problème des
punaises de lit on est on l'a dit ça ne
transmet pas de maladie dit par contre
ça peut amener plutôt de de l'anxiété du
stress de l'angoisse de l'isolement
social et ça c'est vraiment
problématique c'est plutôt ça qui va
poser problème donc on ne panique pas
euh on met tout son tout son linge de
lit à la machine à laver on va le mettre
à une température le plus haut possible
donc au-dessus de 60° c'est très bien on
évite les les les cycles de lavage trop
court donc on va plutôt privilégier les
cycles de lavage coton lin parce que que
vous voulez ensuite on va essayer de
trouver un Balet vapeur ça c'est super
parce que les insecticides qu'on trouve
dans les commerces ne marche plus donc
c'est même plus la peine les punaises
sont devenus résistantes c'est ça c'est
ça ça coûte très cher et c'est
complètement inutile donc vraiment on on
utilise pas en plus c'est souvent pas
bon pour votre santé donc en plus encore
raison de plus de pas l'utiliser ok ok
donc on va plutôt aller chercher vers la
vapeur et là la vapeur chaude qui peut
monter à 120° on va passer doucement sur
chaque recoin de son lit et tout tout ce
qui est table de
Chevé le sol les petits recoins les
trucs qu'on fait jamais là c'est ça
voilà bah c'est l'occase on y va voilà
exactement et et on va faire ça pendant
une semaine si on continue à avoir des
signes et qu'on voit maintenant les
individus parce que quand vous voyez
plusieurs individus c'est que là vous
avez quand même une invasion qui
commence à être conséquente là vous
pouvez vous référer à des professionnels
sachant que ça a un prix c'est un coout
faut le savoir mais que voilà c'est
environ 800 € par par intervention donc
ça peut monter ou et et il faut essayer
de voir si vous êtes locataire ça c'est
super important à préciser c'est à votre
propriétaire normalement de prendre en
charge fesse de lit bon savoir ça ouais
ok d'accord un tonnerur
d'applaudissement pour Lena mesdames et
messieurs pour c super conseil merci
beaucoup Lena vraiment pour ça je pense
qu'il y a un petit truc à préciser que
j'ai vraiment envie de de mettre
l'accent c'est que c'est pas une
question d'hygiène les punaises de lit
il n'y a rien qui dit que les personnes
qui ne se qui ne changent pas s ont leur
draps qui qui ne se lavent pas qui ont
des problèmes d'hygiène ont plus de
problèmes de lit c'est vraiment une
quelque chose qui pe pouve rien vous
nêtes pour rien êtes pour rien vous avez
très peu de chance de ramener des
punaises de lit si vous prenez les
précautions sur votre lieu de travail
dans les transports que vous prenez il y
a il y a pas à à culpabiliser d'avoir
des punaises de lit et il y a pas à
culpabiliser de demander de l'aide pour
les invasions punaises de lit c'est
quelque chose qui peut arriver à tout le
monde même bras les couper en a eu ouais
donc c'est bon ou oui non mais donc si
bras les couperer en a eu ne vous y ne
vous ou
ne vous mettez pas en isolement et
surtout demandz de l'aide et notamment à
des pro des professionnels de la
psychologie parce que ne restez pas avec
des problèmes comme ça on voit que les
gens qui ont eu des punaises de lit il y
a un gros pourcentage qui vont après
consulter pour des problèmes d'anxiété
de stress et d'insomnie et ça on veut
pasou et je précise que le gouvernement
déclenche demain un conseil
interministériel sur le sujet des
annonces sont peut-être attendu dans la
foulée donc on verra si les pouvoirs
publics mettront quelque chose de
spécifique en place chers amis Valentine
la Lena excuse-moi grande particularité
cette année dans l'émission backsit on
voulait inviter à nouveau des créatrices
de contenu et je suis super content de
vous accueillir parce que c'était
vraiment génial cette partie mais ça va
être encore mieux puisqu'on vous a
proposé de mettre en avant quelque chose
qui vous intéresse une cause une
association un truc comme ça et Lena
quand on t'a proposé tu nous as dit
ouais moi je voudrais parler de sciences
participativ chers amis j'ai le plaisir
de vous demander d'accueillir sur ce
plateau Manon gislin qui est docteur en
écologie au Muséum d'histoire
naturelle
bonsoir Manon ça se prononce Guilin je
suis absolument désolé c'est pas grave
tout le monde fait l'erreur merci Manon
tu es donc je le disais docteur en
écologie au Muséum d'Histoire Naturelle
tu t'es intéressé aux sciences
participatives oui tu peux nous dire ce
que c'est déjà alors l'idée des sciences
participatives c'est de remettre les
citoyens au cœur des programmes de
recherche donc tout le monde peut
participer pour servir à des questions
scientifiques pour que les les
chercheurs puissent répondre à des
questions scientifiques se pose donc
l'idée c'est de à la fois sensibiliser
le grand public à à des questions
scientifiques sur la biodiversité il y
en a aussi sur la géologie d'ailleurs
sur plein de plein de questions
différentes tout en permettant Deir de
fournir énormément de données à des
scientifiques à moindre coût parce qu'on
a pas beaucoup d'argent dans la
recherche et donc ça permet vraiment
d'avoir beaucoup de données à grande
échelle pour répondre à des questions
par que j'allais demander parce que
j'allais demander à quoi ça sert pour un
chercheur une chercheuse d'avoir plein
de gens qui viennent l'emmerder il est
tranquille dans son labo il connaît son
truc et en fait non au contraire c'estil
y a des chercheurs qui on on même besoin
oui par exemple on a un programme qui
s'appelle oiseau des jardins où les
particulierers ont juste à compter les
oiseaux qu'il voient dans leur jardin et
euh depuis sa création il y a 10 ans il
y a plus de 100000 jardins qui ont
participé donc plus de 100000 jardins où
il y a eu des comptages ce qui est
impossible à faire pour un scientifique
tout seul j'avais fait une émission avec
la surf rider fondation qui met des
bracelets au pied des surfeurs des
nageurs des plongeurs pour avoir des
datas sur la qualité de l'eau et du coup
ils ont un mapage incroyable euh de la
qualité de l'eau qui peuvent monitorer
quotidiennement parce que juste des gens
vont dans l'eau donc tant qu'à faire
filer un coup de maain scientifique je
viens d'y penser mais ça fait partie de
ces exemples là oui oui aussi des
exemples sur la qualité de l'air où on
fait fabriquer aux gens des petits kits
qui peuvent mettre à leur fenêtre pour
mesurer la qualité de l'air chez eux
alors j'allais te demander ça veut dire
que nous tous là là là nous tous les
gens qui nous regardent on peut aider
des scientifiques oui tout le monde peut
participer on a pas besoin d'un d'un
niveau particulier il y a plein de
programmes qui sont ouverts au débutants
après il y a des programmes qui
demandent plus de qualification mais ce
qui est bien c'est que quand on commence
à à s'intéresser bah on se forme sur le
form et oui y a aussi des formations
etah si je reprendsemple d'oiseaux des
jardins en fait c'est pas très compliqué
d'identifier les oiseaux et de les
reconnaître une fois qu'on a un
référentiel des espèces les plus
communes c'est très facile en fait je
suis infoutu de différencier de Piaf
maintenant que tu poses la question je
me rends compte que j'aurais peut-être
besoin de cette formation non mais en
vrai ouis non c'est hyper intéressant
qu'est-ce qui t'a intéressé toi au
départ dans la science participative
alors moi je travaille sur la
surveillance de la biodiversité OK et
donc sur l'état des populations animal
végétal et cetera et c'est très
compliqué d'avoir des données notamment
dans les outr-mers moi je travaille
surtout sur les outrmers où en fait il y
a pas forcément autant de scientifiqu et
cetera et on a très peu de données sur
sur sur ces territoirees et et il y a
aussi une question de de de
décolonisation un peu de la nature et
cetera c'est que c'est pas à nous
parisien du Muséum d'aller dans les
territoires leur dire vous devez faire
ça ça ça et donc c'est vrai que les
sciences participatives c'est quelque
chose qu'on met très en avant pour pour
former les gens même dès l'école pour
qu'ils s'intéressent vraiment à la
nature et qu' qu' prennent les choses en
main vous aussi en tant que on parlait
tout à l'heure en tant que créatrice de
contenu le rapport à la communauté vous
c'est c'est un truc que vous encouragez
les les gens de faire toi tu fais un
grand oui de la tête lard mais oui on
parle de la biodiversité les insectes ça
a du sens complètement bah du coup moi
ce que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai essayé
de montrer du coup bah l'application
dont tu vas parler après et des sciences
participatives à mes abonnés et on a
fait une espèce de petite course à celui
qui allait identifier le plus d'espèces
et et du coup c'était assez sympa parce
qu'en plus c'est vachement vachement
communautaire on peut on peut échanger
là-dessus et et je vois qu'en fait il y
a un engouement si les gens peuvent
aider bon en vrai il y en a plein qui
sont hyper partants quoi et il suffit
juste de leur donner les moyens et
souvent j'ai plein de gens qui me disent
ah bah trop bien j'ai commencé à faire
les insectes et puis je me suis rendu
compte que je connaissais vachement plus
les oiseaux donc j'ai fait les oiseaux
et ah bah j'ai vu que c'était trop bien
j'avais plein de de de plantes chez moi
donc j'ai aussi fait les plantes et au
final bah c'est génial non mais c'est
trop cool et toi Valentine les cailloux
ouais bah tu rigoles mais il y a
effectivement un programme de sciences
participative autour des caillou qui
s'appelle vigiter fait par le Muséum
national d'histoire naturelle et j'ai
j'ai bossé avec eux effectivement le but
c'est tu te balades et tu vois un
affleurement donc des roches qui
affleurent et tu peux les signaler dans
leur cartte en disant oui ça c'est telle
roche je pense machin et ça aide
effectivement les scientifiques qui s'en
servent après pour cartographier le
patrimoine géologique alors parmi parmi
tous ces programmes dont tu as parlé il
y en a un qui a retenu notre attention
qui s'appelle l'INPN espèce et c'est une
sorte de Pokémon Go de la biodiversité
c'est ça c'est comme un Pokémon Go le
but c'est de voir le plus d'espèces
possibles et surtout de les voir dans
des endroits où elles ont pas core été
répertorié dans nos bases de données
donc par exemple je me promène je vois
un oiseau un insecte n'importe quoi je
vais le prendre en photo le mettre sur
l'application essayer de l'identifier
dans la mesure du possible alors pour
les oiseaux ça peut être assez simple
pour les insectes bah ça peut être vite
plus compliqué donc on peut essayer de
se renseigner sur Internet et cetera si
on sait pas c'est pas grave on peut
juste dire c'est un insecte et après en
fait il y a des experts qui vont valider
l'observation identifier au mieux si ça
pas été fait donc moi par par exemple
jealide les oiseaux on en a je sais pas
une centaine d'observations par jour
donc on doit valider c'est c'est bien la
bonne espèce qui au moin une fois par
jour tu tu regardes des photos d'oiseau
et tu les identifies c'est mon petit
rituel du matin en vivant mon café non
mais c'est trop bien bah surtout qu'à
Paris on en voit pas beaucoup donc ça
fait un peu voyager en France tous les
matins professeur cha des oiseaux en
fait c'est ça professeur cha des oiseaux
tu l'as avec toi l'application parce que
c'est une appli don don on vous parle tu
nous en fait une démo oui alors je sais
pas si ça marche normalement c'est
branché à l'écran normalement c'est
incroyable on est au top de la techno
voilà regardez ça apparaît c'est fou
vas-y montre-nous cet appli à quoi elle
ressemble alors donc on a un accueil
avec une présentation un peu de mes
dernières observations on peut découvrir
alors faut choisir une ville on l'a pas
fait mais on peut découvrir un peu les
les animaux les plantes qu'on a autour
de chez nous et donc par exemple si je
veux poster une nouvelle
observation je vais sur nouvelle
observation je vais dans mes photos sur
mon téléphone et donc par exemple si
j'ai vu une pi là en venant tout à
l'heure que j'ai pris en photo je
l'ajoute donc j'ajoute une date donc et
la date et l'heure bon on met au hasard
c'est pas très grave là et on met
l'endroit où on l' prise alors soit on
peut localiser exactement là de son
téléphone ou alors on l'indique là je
vais mettre
Paris hop
hop voilà ensuite on peut dire le groupe
simple dans lequel auquel il appartient
bon là c'est facile c'est un oiseau oh
j'ai mis ça jusque là je l'avais jusque
là c'est ouais alors le groupe
taxonomique donc la p ça fait partie des
passerau ça
s'appelle c'est dans la même famille que
c'est pas très intuitif que les
maisanges les moineau et cetera et
ensuite on met le nom d'espèce alors
soit on peut mettre le nom commun soit
on peut mettre le nom latin si on le
connaît alors la pie c'est assez rigolo
son n latin c'est Pik pica donc la
petite préférence à Pokémon Go
encore voilà la p
bavarde et ensuite on a juste envoyer
l'observation et ce sera ce sera validé
par des experts ensuite et alors là
jusque là vous pouvez vous dire bon bah
d'accord super je prends des photos de
Piaf et je identifie mais en fait non il
y a des quêtes oui il y a a
l'application vous donne des quêtes les
gamers alors il y a des par exemple des
gestionnaires d'espac naturels ou même
des villes qui veulent avoir des
informations sur des espèces ils savent
pas si par exemple le hisson est présent
dans telle ou telle ville donc si sur
les quêtes par exemple là à Mayotte ils
ont lancé une quête récemment sur les
reptiles il y a aussi là pour pour
l'automne il y a une une quête sur les
champignons où on nous demande de
trouver des des des espèce en
particulier et donc si on trouve ces
espèces en particulier on a des points
en plus ah trop bien oui parce que ce
que j'ai pas dit c'est que dès qu'on
poste une observation on a des points si
on identifie l'espèce correctement et si
c'est une espèce qui a jamais été vue
dans la ville ou dans le département on
a encore plus de points bonus les pour
les gens qui posent la question dans le
chat depuis tout à l'heure l'application
s'appelle
inpn espèce elle est disponible sur
l'App Store sur vos iPhone elle est
disponible sur le Google Play Store pour
vos Android installez-la
c'est trop trop cool alors vous du coup
les scientifiques une fois que vous avez
ça comment vous travaillez avec comment
vous fonctionnez alors en fait bah
beaucoup on est aussi validateur donc on
voit déjà passer des observations
intéressantes en validant mais également
alors par exemple là il y a des
particuliers qui ont trouvver des
espèces de cololéoptèr qui avaient
jamais été vu dans l'Est de la France
ces deux espèces on savait pas qu'elles
étaient là-bas et cetera donc déjà c'est
super intéressant pour la distribution
des
espèces aussi pour suivre les espèces en
ante par exemple le frelon asiatique ou
la la la la perruche à colier qu'on voit
partout dans Paris c'est super
intéressant parce qu'on a plein de
données en fait gratuitement plein de
données qui arrivent et donc qui
permettent de connaître mieux la
distribution de ces espèces vous avez eu
depuis janvier dernier 300000
observations et 24000 contributeurs
l'application a été lancée en 2018 et il
y a 300 experts validateurs comme toi
qui valident et il y a plus de 18000
espèces recensé c'est énorme oui mais
euh ou ou pas suffisant parce que je
t'ai vu je t mais en fait il y a des
espèces par exemple les les oiseaux dans
l'Hexagone on connaît leur distribution
c'est c'est c'est super intéressant mais
ça il y a pas vraiment beaucoup de
nouvelles informations par contre dans
les dans les outr-mers en Guyane par
exemple les oiseaux il y en a plein il y
a plein d'espèces on n' pas
d'information et donc là c'est super
important même sur les plantes même sur
les insectes c'est super important
d'avoir des informations parce que la
base pour protéger une espèce c'est de
savoir où est-ce qu'elle habite où
est-ce qu'elle vit et euh et voilà quoi
si on n pas un minimum de connaissance
on peut pas les protéger quelqu'un qui
pose la question de savoir est-ce que ça
marche à l'étranger ou est-ce que c'est
que en France alors c'est que en France
à l'étranger il y a a naturaliste ça
s'appelle et ben voilà quelqu'un dans le
chat qui l'a mis incroyable merci vous
vous êtes formidable non mais c'est
c'est c'est vraiment une application
super super intéressante et ça permet de
rendre un service très direct au
scientifiqu ça permet aussi je suppose
bah de enfin de de découvrir aussi des
insectes des oiseaux enfin juste si tu
as l'appli tu fais plus attention au
Piaf que tu croises ouis complètement et
en plus on peut la combiner si on on
n'est pas très à l'aise on peut la
combiner avec des applications a pour
reconnaître les oiseaux les insectes les
plantes et du coup si on n'est pas
forcément très assuré sur nos nos
découvertes et ben on met la photo
d'abord dans une application Dia qui
nous donne une espèce et là on peut la
faire valider par des experts qui vont
du coup de toute façon vérifier très
précisément quelle est l'espèce et du
coup valider après par la suite donc
c'est super on peut combiner les deux
est-ce que la base de données des
résultats est ouverte oui alors c'est
pour ça j'encourage plutôt à mettre un
pseudo si vous partagez vos observations
parce qu'en fait tout le monde peut voir
qui a été vu et où donc c'est est super
intéressant moi des fois je me dis mince
est-ce que telle espèce elle est là j'ai
pas besoin de demander une extraction de
données compliqué je vais sur le site je
tape l'espèce le lieu bah j'ai
l'information mais voilà niveau niveau
information personnelle mettez un pseudo
si tu'as pas dit à ton mec que tu en all
en voir un autre et que tu croises un
Piave voilà mais pas ton nom au moment
où tu prends la photo ça fait gênant
enfin bref voilà on a compris
impressionnant Manon où est-ce qu'on te
retrouve le Muséum National d'Histoire
Naturelle ça se visite
c'est ça venez le visiter venez le
visiter merci beaucoup Manon
l'application in PN espèce gratuit à
télécharger sur vos téléphone Lena où
est-ce qu'on te retrouve ta chaîne sur
YouTube Instagram et TikTok et Manon
aussi fait des vidéos sur Instagram elle
l'a pas dit mais elles sont super
intéressante même s'il en a pas beaucoup
voilà je lu dis et ben tu l'as pas dit
donc Manon c'est quoi ton insta c'est
Manon forsteri c'est pas du tout ça
sécrit comment for O R S T e r i c'est
le nom latin du mancho empereur let's go
man for on te retrouve sur insta et ben
écoute c'est super donc toi scarbet on
l'a dit sur les réseaux sociaux qui vont
bien Valentine on te retrouve vous
science de comptoir non c'est pas ça la
question sur Youtube YouTube chance de
comptoir ouais YouTube Twitter Instagram
TikTok twish ouais voilà et l'émission
d'artescope l'émission d'artescope
réalisé par notre Nicolas national qui
réalise cette émission Nicolas qui
réalise backseed qui réalise également
l'émission scope merci beaucoup à toutes
les trois un tonur d'applaudissement
chers amis on va se un générique et on
va enchaîner avec le début de notre
émission merite à tout de
[Musique]
suite